kevin costner's 1990 directorial debut
dances with wolves set the standard for
modern historical epics a big reason for
its success was the talent of the actors
who brought the tragic story to life
let's take a look at what the cast is
doing now including the wolves
themselves
from 1987 to 1993 kevin costner was on
top of the cinematic world crowd
pleasers mixed with prestige projects in
his filmography garnering praise from
critics and big box office receipts
thanks to fans his breakout role of
elliott ness in 1987's the untouchables
snagged him major attention which was
followed by a string of now classic
films including no way out bull durham
field of dreams jfk the bodyguard and a
perfect world tucked in the middle of
those gems is the film that cemented his
legacy dances with wolves which earned
him two oscars a string of flops and
poorly received films followed including
the much derided water world and the
postman which he also directed still
costner kept busy and continued to
please fans in the decades to come with
romantic comedies thrillers and further
gallops into westerns in fact as
patriarch john dutton on paramount's
2018 series yellowstone costner has
managed to find new success in the
western genre
after 20 years on stage and tv the early
1990s brought new fame and acclaim to
mary mcdonald she was twice nominated
for best actress at the academy awards
the first nomination honored her
portrayal of stans with a fist in dances
with wolves while the second arrived two
years later for her performance as may
alice culhane in 1993's passionfish
mcdonald's career continued to flourish
in the years following this surge of
success she's played strong
multi-dimensional female characters on
screens big and small including the
first lady in independence day and fan
favorite president laura roslin on the
beloved sci-fi series battle star
galactica she's also had emmy nominated
guest appearances on er and the closer
as fans of dances with wolves could have
guessed all the way back in 1990
mcdonnell has made a sterling career out
of playing complex women in unique
situations
the world has gifted us two talented
gram greens and both have provided
endless entertainment between them
however the english novelist should not
be confused with the oneida actor who
boasts over 160 credited roles green's
gentle and soulful work as kicking bird
in dances with wolves earned him his one
and only academy award nomination for
best supporting actor unfortunately he
lost out to joe pesci from goodfellas
green did however take home a grammy for
best spoken word album for children in
2000. for the album listen to the
storyteller among his other notable work
are parts in thunderheart maverick the
green mile skins and molly's game which
reunited him with kevin costner
john dunbar finds his spirituality
through literally dancing with wolves
which is of course how he gets his name
two socks was the only wolf character in
the film but he was played by two
different grey timberwolves teddy and
buck teddy did a majority of the work
with buck serving as backup this wasn't
the only time the canine pair would work
together in fact they were practically a
double act the two wolves paired up
again for an episode of star trek the
next generation as well as 1994's the
jungle book buck gained the spotlight
with a small uncredited role in 1994's
lassie with teddy serving as his backup
after enjoying their long hollywood
career the two wolves hung up their
dancing and acting shoes and retired to
california's wolf mountain sanctuary
teddy passed away around 1997 and buck
followed the year after
after watching sam waterston play a
native american in 1979's eagle's wing
omaha tribe member rodney a grant knew
he had to go to la and bring some
authenticity to the film industry after
a few minor roles he broke through to
the big time when he was cast in dances
with wolves as wind in his hair
choline
casting director elizabeth lustig summed
up his appeal nicely he had a great
contrast in his personality between
ferocity and childishness the contrast
between when he smiles and when he's
serious is amazing
not one to rely on hollywood for a
career he also worked as a furniture
mover when dances with wolves hit the
big screen grande has also been very
active promoting various causes close to
his heart including advocacy on behalf
of native american youth and fetal
alcohol syndrome awareness grant has
been busy on screen as well however the
last few decades have seen him appear in
everything from sci-fi projects like
ghosts of mars to dramas like don't come
knocking
floyd redcrow westerman had already
enjoyed a well-established career as a
musician and activist by the time he
appeared in dances with wolves his first
album custer died for your sins was
released in 1969. he went on to
collaborate and tour with the likes of
sting harry belafonte willie nelson
bonnie raitt joni mitchell chris
christopherson and jackson brown as the
open-minded and friendly ten bears his
talents were put on display to a wide
audience numerous other roles followed
usually wise elders or chiefs westerman
stayed busy right up until his death
from leukemia in 2007. he released a new
album a tribute to johnny cash in 2006
and even reunited with kevin costner in
his final screen appearance in the 2008
film swing vote
rose marie cardinal was dubbed tantu by
her grandmother after the insect
repellent they used while picking
blueberries together in her youth that's
not the only thing she gave young tantu
she also blessed her granddaughter with
an appreciation of her cree and metis
ancestry and an interest in acting
cardinal's career began early in life
breaking screen barriers long before
dances with wolves but the film's
success opened even more doors for the
actress cardinal went on to appear in
such hits as legends of the fall smoke
signals and wind river wind river
reunited her with graham green and not
for the first time they've worked
together on over 20 different projects
cardinal has won numerous accolades for
her work she took home the prestigious
earl grey award from the canadian screen
awards in 2017 and was made a member of
the order of canada one of the country's
highest civilian honors in 2009
aboriginal canadian jimmy herman first
got involved in acting when he appeared
in a yellow pages ad he then worked as a
narrator for the native counseling
services of alberta bit by bit and part
by part herman increased his profile as
a performer until he caught his big
break when he was cast as the elder
warrior stone calf in dances with wolves
a career was born that day over the next
17 years hermann worked on over 40
projects including playing a bartender
in john frankenheimer's reindeer games
and appearing in a guest spot on the
x-files for a number of those years
hermann played fur trapper joe gumba on
cbc's north of 60. off-screen he was
very giving of his time for those in
need herman was sober for 30 years but
still attended aa meetings to help those
still working to conquer their addiction
hermann died in 2013 of a heart attack
at the age of 72.
brooklyn-born maury chaikin often played
outsized characters his brief but highly
tense scene in dances with wolves ended
up being one of his most memorable roles
other works of node included parts and
war games my cousin vinnie and a
memorably harvey weinstein-esque
character named harvey weingard on hbo's
entourage in 1994 he won a genie award
for his work as an isolated former rock
star in whale music in another rare lead
part jaken excelled in his portrayal of
the titular new york detective in the
2001-2002 a a series a nero wolf mystery
busy until the very end jaken passed
away in 2010 on his 61st birthday due to
complications of a heart valve infection
in a film without much room for laughter
robert pastorelli definitely brought
some much-needed comic relief to dances
with wolves as costner's flatulent wagon
chauffeur timmons pastorelli brought
further smiles to the small screen
appearing as the title characters ever
present house painter eldon brunecki
from 158 episodes of murphy brown in
1999 pastorelli's girlfriend and the
mother of his child died under
mysterious circumstances authorities
eventually determined that she had
killed herself pastarelli's life and
career deteriorated sharply thereafter
he did manage to form a close friendship
with glenn close and the two appeared in
a pair of tv movies together in 2001 in
2004 pastorelli overdosed and died at
the age of 49. it was eventually
revealed that at the time of his death
he had been a suspect in janovich's
death
nathan lee chasing his horse also known
as nathan chasing horse born on the
rosebud lakota sioux reservation popped
up in a few tv movies after appearing in
dances with wolves things picked up in
the 2000s in the 2005 tv miniseries into
the west he appeared as sleeping bear in
three episodes in 2015 chasing horse ran
afoul of the fort peck reservation and
was banned from ever returning
accusations of quote human trafficking
drug dealing spiritual abuse and
intimidation of tribal members were
cited as motivation for the ban
michael spears made his green debut by
beating out 500 other boys for the role
of playful young tribe member otter in
dances with wolves he has gone on to act
in over 20 projects many in the western
genre he even reunited with fellow
castmates nathan lee chasing his horse
in graham greene in a number of projects
including the acclaimed 2005 tnt series
into the west spears has also worked
alongside his brother eddie the two are
celebrated hand drummers
tony pierce's spivey is the sort of
character you love to hate an army
soldier with a disdain for the native
friendly dunbar and everything he stands
for he makes quite the splash in the
film's final act in real life however he
and costner are friends and appeared
together again in 1992's the bodyguard
where he played whitney houston stalker
pierce has had a decent run of
supporting work playing wise guys and
intense weirdos in such films as for the
boys and big bully opposite rick moranis
more recently he played a crazed
homeless man on ray donovan things have
slowed down significantly for the actor
since then pierce hasn't acted on screen
since 2015.
kirk bald has not only earned high
praise for his acting skills but for his
work as a teacher and coach as well when
balt enters a scene the brash and mouthy
actor's presence is immediately felt his
most memorable role is likely the
beleaguered police officer marvin nash
who is bound to a chair tortured and
ultimately has his ear cut off to the
sound of stuck in the middle with you in
quentin tarantino's reservoir dogs
beyond this balt has appeared on a slew
of popular tv shows including the ever
popular ncis
[Music]
oregon native tom everett played the
salty battle scarred soldier sergeant
pepper and he's built a robust career in
supporting roles since the late 70s in
2000 he reunited with costner for the
cuban missile crisis thriller 13 days
and recently appeared as archbishop
terrazzi on hellstrom in 1971 rca
released his one and only album
porchlight on in oregon
wes duty has quite the resume both on
and off the screen in addition to being
an actor he's a horse trainer stone
carver musician children's author the
founder of bilingual newspaper a vietnam
war veteran and an activist with the
american indian movement his work and
dances with wolves opened the door to a
steady career as an actor on the stage
and in tv and movies including roles in
the last of the mohicans heat mystery
men the new world and the title
character in 1993's geronimo an american
legend in 2019 he received the
governor's award from the academy of
motion pictures arts and sciences
studies shows no signs of slowing down
he recently lent his voice to disney's
soul
kevin costner's eldest offspring annie
costner landed her first role as a child
she filled in stands with a fist's
backstory by playing the heroine's
childhood self annie later went on to
act in two more of her dad's films
waterworld and the postman in 2014 she
co-founded soundoff films a production
company specializing in quote
mission-driven content of all stripes as
part of sound off costner's work
includes an espn 3430 short about a
short-lived 70s coed volleyball league
entitled bump spike
born charles adams clavery charles
rocket first appeared on screen as a
local tv news anchor in colorado and
nashville he then utilized his good
humor and looks to land on saturday
night live for the
1980-1981 season he was a major player
and even managed to snag a seat at the
weekend update desk but after he dropped
the f-bomb on air and clashed with other
actors and producers behind the scenes
he and a few other cast members
including gilbert gottfried were let go
after one season that dismissal did
little to slow him down as rocket
followed it up with roles in dances with
wolves we're charged with apprehending
hostiles and recovering stolen property
earth girls are easy and dumb and dumber
sadly rocket committed suicide in 2005
at the age of 56.
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call or chat
online with the national suicide
prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-talk 8255
or text home to the crisis text line 741
741